hello everybody and welcome back to our
financial charting tutorial we have
completed everything for actual like
stock price acquisition and the exact
same method that we use to gather the
stock prices you can use to gather Forex
data at Yahoo does Forex as well so now
what we want to do is once we actually
have these prices like generally you
want to do something with it now you can
do almost all you the analysis and
generate you know you can generate the
RSI and you can generate all kinds of
stuff and you don't actually have to
visualize it right it just only helps us
understand it visually you know but
generally the next step is going to be
to actually visualize the data and
there's all kinds of like programs out
there that will automatically do this
for you and all kinds of like all kinds
of analysis and stuff but it's really
beneficial to be able to one do it
yourself just so you can get exactly the
analysis that you want and then also
later on if you ever want to make like
automatic trading or algorithmic trading
and you want to do it based off of your
own chart analysis that you've built
yourself then you're gonna well you
don't have to but this would be a very
beneficial skill to have to do that so
anyways let's get started with actually
charting this stuff so the first thing
that we need is a way to actually chart
the stuff and for that we're going to
need a couple of things the first thing
we're going to need is mat plot Lib now
I do have an entire series on just
matplotlib just everything to do with
mat plot live and I'll probably throw
these videos in that series as well but
I'll continue them in this series too so
you don't have to like hop around and
find the other playlist so the first
thing that we need is matplotlib and it
just so happens I'm on matplotlib well
what are the odds anyway so the website
is matplotlib dot org once you get there
there used to be a little downloads link
up here but they've removed it so now
you just scroll down a little bit
here it'll say download and visit the
Matt plugins download page and you
probably want to download the latest
stable version it really I don't know
what the dates are on some of these but
I prime not even sure I've the most
up-to-date version but anyway you get
want to download the version you have I
told you to download Python to seven so
you want to do that and depending on
which version of Python whether you got
a 32-bit or 64-bit that's what you're
going to have to download I recommended
that you get 64-bit but if you're on a
32-bit operating system you're kind of
Sol so download whichever one that you
need also if you're on like a Linux or
something like that you can just
download the tarball yeah so anyways
that's map hot live just downloaded go
through the installer if you find
yourself kind of like hung up you could
check out the matplotlib series but it's
pretty basic if you're getting an error
you've probably downloaded like the
wrong yeah it says it can't find python
you've probably downloaded you know
64-bit when you're running 32-bit python
etc so anyways that's where you get Matt
plot lib now the next thing that we need
is a program called numpy it'll help us
a whole lot it's definitely one of the
best one of the best of like imports for
python in my opinion so to get numpy
probably will just go to google i can't
type google comm and then just type in
like numpy download and let's see numpy
org pretty sure it's not going to be
here but let's see
hold on yeah I didn't think it would be
realistic numpy all right they're
probably right here yeah so then you'll
come over here this is the URL but if
you google it you should be able to find
pi pi but it's p YP i python org slash p
YP i slash n um p y scroll down and
again you'll see we've got basically the
same kind of setup as we did before
although this one only has a windows 32
but it does work with 64 so don't worry
about that
and then also obviously if you're not on
Windows you can use just the tarball if
you're on a Linux operating system II so
that's all the stuff that you're going
to need once you have all that stuff
downloaded and installed you can begin
this tutorial so what I think I'm going
to do now is pause video here we'll
continue on in the next video sorry to
do that to you guys but you definitely
gonna want to make sure you have all
this stuff done to check it go to your
Start bar whatever you have and type in
just Python and open up that Python
command line so here's my Python command
line and do two things one import mat
plot lib this is just basically if you
don't throw like it doesn't say an error
like if I did import mat right it throws
this right it says there's no module
called that but if you import matplotlib
and you don't have like any error like
that then it means you installed
matplotlib correctly now the next thing
we're going to want to check is numpy so
import numpy and if you don't throw any
errors that means you've installed it
correctly so once you're to that point
continue on to the next video